now we begin at a tense time for
america's schools as millions of kids
head back to school and head to the
classroom former fda commissioner
advisor board member scott godley
estimates vaccines for kids as young as
five could be approved by the end of
october and they're hopeful
that as more than a million new york
students return to school today now
despite extensive precautions some
parents are worried and here's why there
are more than 750 000 confirmed cases of
coronavirus and kids between august 5th
and september 2nd meg oliver is
following this for us right here in new
york the nation's largest school
district meg good morning
nate good morning in less than an hour
these school doors behind me will open
about 65 percent of eligible students
and roughly 75 percent of school staff
are vaccinated school officials say
their safety protocols are the gold
standard but that still hasn't convinced
some parents who say the city is pushing
some kids into unsafe conditions
our principals are ready our teachers
are ready our students are ready we're
ready we're ready i can't wait for new
york city schools chancellor misha
porter the return to the classroom is a
milestone one she's worked hard for
since taking over in march she says
masks will be required in the classroom
almost every room has at least two air
purifiers and all school staff must be
vaccinated despite all that there are a
lot of nervous parents how do you
reassure them that it is safe to send
their kids back to school
first i'm sending my own kid back to
school into a new york city public
school and so i know parents are nervous
i think what's important is we agree and
we all agree that the best learning
happens in person between students and
teachers and we have done the work to
get our buildings safe to get them ready
so that we can do what's most important
for children it's a fulfillment of a
promise from mayor bill de blasio who
told cbs news in march he wanted every
student back in class by september now
meg do i think there's going to be
parents and kids who are not ready even
in september yes of course do we have to
have a remote option for them yes we do
but some parents aren't satisfied with
the city's current remote option like
jennifer goddard her 10 year old son
august isn't old enough for the vaccine
and while he has asthma and other
underlying conditions she says he
doesn't automatically qualify for the
city's medically fragile exemption and
can't stay home to force people back
into these situations
is
it's an abomination once he's vaccinated
it is a game changer right and he will
be the first kid in line i just don't
understand the rush and the force
goddard says she's terrified after
seeing covet cases close schools and
fill pediatric icus across the south at
the end of august u.s pediatric coveted
cases hit an all-time high how do you
prevent that from happening in the
nation's largest school district
continue to follow the health and safety
protocols i am confident that we're
ready that we won't have the closures
that we're seeing in other states
because of where we are without
vaccination rates how much pressure do
you feel to get this right we have to
get it right there's no option
students like ten-year-old august can
apply for a medical exemption and be
placed in a home education program but
there's no guarantee the department of
education will grant the request
chancellor porter told us right now
there is no plan to mandate the vaccine
for all new york city students but they
are closely monitoring districts like
los angeles that did tony
and we'll keep monitoring as well meg
thank you very much